let's review the Calvin cycle a little
bit maybe I'm gonna go into a little bit
more details in the last video and by
doing that we'll be able to appreciate
an inefficiency or what we think is an
inefficiency that occurs in many
photosynthetic plants so just a review
of the Calvin cycle you start off with
some co2 in the last video I had six
molecules of co2 and six molecules of
ribulose by phosphate but in this one
just to show you that I could have
literally just divided that last that
last cycle by two I'm gonna start with
three and three three molecules of
carbon dioxide three molecules of
ribulose biphosphate if you don't
remember what ribulose biphosphate was
it was just a five carbon it was just a
five carbon molecule it had two
phosphates on it I could draw the
phosphates so you have a phosphate there
and you have a phosphate there and we
saw in the last video and here I'm gonna
do a little bit more detail and of
course carbon dioxide there's only one
carbon here and I could just draw a
carbon like that I mean I don't want to
draw the oxygens right now I just want
to focus on just the carbons and maybe
the phosphates but in the last video we
saw that these two merged or these two
reacted they reacted in the presence of
ribulose biphosphate carboxylase which
is this enzyme it was that big protein
that I showed you in the last video and
it's called Rubisco for short so I'm
gonna write I'm gonna put Co in the
middle of this whole cycle because all
of this is going on along with the
Rubisco enzyme these molecules are
joining on to the Rubisco enzyme and
then the ATP and the NADH is are
reacting on different parts and that's
essentially what's driving the whole
reaction so you have all of this is
happening with that big Rubisco Rubisco
protein or enzyme or whatever you want
to call it and this just stands for
ribulose biphosphate carboxylate so it's
essentially telling you that it merges a
carbon onto ribulose biphosphate and the
last video i just you know i just did a
very hand wavy I didn't show you all of
the intermediates but I showed you look
if in this situation you end up using
six ATP's and
and a DHS you'll end up with
glyceraldehyde 3 phosphate or g3p or
that's also called phosphoglyceraldehyde
so you could also write it as P gal but
a very easy way to visualize it it was
just a three carbon chain with a
phosphate with a phosphate group and in
the last video when I started three
carbon dioxides and three ribulose or in
the last video I started with six carbon
dioxides and six ribulose biphosphate
and I ended up with 12 of these now I
have three and three so now I'm gonna
end up with six of these so I'm gonna
end up with six g3ps and the math works
out right I have three carbons plus
three times five carbons that's a total
of 18 carbons and here I have 6 times 3
carbons or 18 carbons and that's what I
showed you in the last video but there
are actually some intermediary steps
there are some intermediary steps so the
very first thing that's actually formed
this 3 phosphoglycerate 3 phospho
phospho glycerine and the whole reason
why I'm showing you this detail and
maybe you're taking a biology class
where they actually do go into this
level of detail is I want to because
this compound also gets produced in that
inefficient cycle that we're going to
explore in this video so you get 3
phosphoglycerate which is also a three
carbon chain but it's a different one
than this and this isn't ready to
produce glucose just yet but you could
also imagine that as a three carbon
chain with a phosphate group and then
and of course you're going to produce
six of these right just to make sure all
the carbon gets accounted for you have
18 carbons here you're gonna have 18
carbons here so you're gonna have six of
these three phosphoglycerates get
produced and then each of those get a
phosphate from it from ATP so you're
gonna have six ATP's come in and
remember these ATP's got produced in the
light dependent reactions that occur in
the in the membrane of our of our
thylakoids but anyway we have these
ATP's you have six ATP's and then they
become six ADP's so essentially they've
given away their phosphate groups
they're gonna
one phosphate group to each of these
three or higher to each of these six
three phosphoglycerates and then you're
gonna end up with this right here
I'm running out of space me I didn't do
it as neatly as I should have
but you're gonna end up with this three
chain carbon or three carbon compound
it's gonna have two phosphates then and
this you know we can you could know the
name this is one three by
phosphoglycerate right this was just 3
phosphoglycerate which means that the
phosphate is on the third carbon now we
have one three by phosphoglycerate we
have a phosphate on the one carbon and
the three carbon we have two of them so
it's by phosphoglycerate and then so
that's to get us right there and then to
get from the 1/3 by phosphoglycerate and
of course we have six of these as well
right six of these turned into six of
these and to turn these 6 1-3 by fossil
glycerides into our three glyceraldehyde
3 phosphates or phosphoglyceraldehyde
the names are very daunting this is
where we are actually going to this is
where we're actually going to oxidize
our NADPH right remember oxidizing is
losing electrons or losing hydrogens
with their electrons either way so here
on this step right here two things are
going to happen actually you're going to
have six na D P and a d th's become six
and a D pluses so they're losing that
hydrogen and the electrons and also one
phosphate is going to be lost from each
of these molecules and then you're gonna
also have +6 of the phosphate groups the
phosphate groups don't get lost here
they get added on to these molecules
right there and then we at we we end up
with our six glyceraldehyde 3 phosphates
which we learned in the last video we
can then use to produce fuel or glucose
or other carbohydrates in the cell but
we also learned that you know this is
the called the Calvin cycle so all of it
doesn't get used to produce actual
glucose or other or other carbohydrates
most of it out of the six five of them
five of them
are going to be used to produce our
three ribulose biphosphate
so let me let me do it like this so
you're gonna have five G three peas go
in that direction so for every six G
three peas you produce five go back into
the cycle and then one exits the cycle
and we saw this in the last video in the
last video I had 12 years so 10 went in
this direction and two in this direction
I'm just dividing everything by two in
this video and the whole reason why I
did it
I'm multiplied by two in the last video
and so that we end up with two going
into this direction because two is
enough to produce at least one glucose
but we don't have to have two we could
just say we do this whole cycle twice to
get two but anyway I have one
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate coming out of
this end and then these five
glyceraldehyde 3 phosphates that stay in
the cycle remember those are just you
know three carbons with a phosphate
group I drew it over here already
they will then use they will then use
another 3 ATP so 3 let me write it this
way 3 ATP 80 ATP so we end up with 3 ad
Peas and the phosphate groups actually
end up on the ribulose biphosphate and
they get essentially recycled into
ribulose biphosphate for the whole cycle
to happen again remember and all of this
is happening you can kind of imagine in
or on the surface of this big enzyme
this ribulose biphosphate carboxylase
and actually just so you you
I guess know a piece of terminology this
type of photosynthesis is called c3
photosynthesis c3 photo synthesis and
the whole reason why it's called c3
photosynthesis is because the very first
product that you get when you when you
react with carbon dioxide and when the
first time you fix your carbon dioxide
remember carbon dioxide fixation is when
you've taken in its gaseous form and
you're actually putting it into a
molecule the very first carbon molecule
you get once the carbon dioxide gets
fixed is a 3 carbon molecule it's
phosphoglycerate that's why I showed it
to
because that's where the c3 fold the 3
in the c3 photosynthesis comes from now
everything I've just done is a review of
what we did in the last video maybe with
a little bit more detail and I showed
you that you don't have to start with 6
& 6 you can start with 3 & 3 & just have
5 go down here and 1 go down here
instead of doubling everything but what
I want to show you now is an
inefficiency that goes on in plants this
Rubisco enzyme doesn't necessarily just
fix carbon dioxide it can also it can
also react with oxygen and actually it's
name is ribulose biphosphate carboxylase
oxygenase which means it can react with
carbon or oxygen and this mechanism so
let's say you have your ribulose
biphosphate hanging around you know
we're in The Strokes we're in the stroma
of some of our of our chloroplasts so
let's say we have our we have our 5
ribulose biphosphate 5 ribulose
biphosphate and instead of reacting with
carbon it can actually react with oxygen
so instead of having carbon dioxide here
I can have Oh - coming in here we have
oxygen coming in here and all of this
once again is occurring on the surface
or with the assistance of the Rubisco
notice of the the exact same the Rubisco
enzyme ribulose biphosphate carboxylase
oxygenase that's why because it can also
fix oxygen and when these two things
react you don't get useful things that
can be used for fuel and all of that the
first you end up with you end up with
and I my drawing is a little messy you
end up with one well if these two guys
react you'll end up with 5 molecules 5
molecules of this guy right here 5
molecules of this 3 phosphoglycerate
right there
remember here we ended up with six of
them but now we're only going out with
five phosphoglycerates five
phosphoglycerates and I know the names
are all very confusing but the basic
idea is to remember that what's
happening here is is carbon dioxide's
isn't getting fixed oxygen can get fixed
and you end up with five
phosphoglycerates and you actually also
end up with five
it's called phospho glycolate I know
these are very daunting names and
phospho glycolate which is a two carbon
molecule which makes sense because we
only have five carbons to start with
this thing right here is a three carbon
molecule that's a three carbon molecule
and this right here is a two carbon
molecule so this right here is going to
be a two carbon molecule and it has a
phosphate group so as you can imagine in
this situation we're not going to be
able to keep going forward and produce
our glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate which we
can then use to make up carbohydrates
we're stuck we just have these five
phosphoglycerates
and we're or these can go on and you
know some percentage of them but you
know the ratios are all getting messed
up but you know everything doesn't
necessarily happen this cleanly in the
cell these things can go on but we have
one less being produced and this thing
right here it's actually using up some
of our carbon from our ribulose
biphosphate and if this thing kept going
up all of our ribulose biphosphate is
gonna get eaten up we're not gonna be
able to continue on into this cycle over
and over again and actually this is kind
of a waste product right here this is a
waste product or we think it's a waste
product and this actually has to exit
your chloroplasts and actually get
processed by other organelles in the
plant cells and these are called these
these kind of waste processing organism
or organelles and your cells these are
peroxisomes they're roxas ohms and it's
a lot of complicated terminology here
but the important thing to remember in
when when Rubisco fixes oxygen this is
actually called photo respiration that's
an important
- no photo respiration all of a sudden
instead of being able to carry forward
with your Calvin cycle and and produce a
lot of sugar instead you're depleting
your Rubisco so this is a very bad
process this is going to get in the way
of your Calvin cycle and remember how
important each of these remember how
important each of these g3ps are right
because for every turn of the Calvin
cycle or at least the way I did it we
only produce one g3p that actually gets
used for something useful
the other five g3ps have to go back to
produce Rubisco again so you can imagine
you can not Rubisco to produce repeat
ribulose biphosphate Rubisco of course
is the enzyme so in this situation we
only have five phosphoglycerates to
begin with maybe if we have our ATP or
NADH we can convert these five you know
it doesn't have to go in this direction
but maybe we can convert these five
phosphoglycerates into five
glyceraldehyde 3 phosphates g3ps but
then all of these are going to be used
back to produce Rupe to produce our
ribulose biphosphate so to go from here
to here we actually had to use up ATP
and NADH and then to go from here to
here we have to use more ATP but we went
through this whole cycle and we didn't
produce anything in terms of useful
things that can be used to you know
essentially sugars or carbohydrates that
can be used to fuel or provide structure
for the plant in any way so this is a
completely or we think this is a
wasteful process wasteful process so it
you know it people wonder you know you
don't when you look at a lot of
biological systems you don't see
wasteful processes all the time you'd
have said well you know wouldn't a
natural selection have selected against
this and some people believe that this
is just a remnant from our evolutionary
past for our plants evolutionary past
where there wasn't a lot of oxygen in
the atmosphere and if there wasn't a lot
of oxygen in the atmosphere this was not
that likely that this wasn't was not
that likely of an occurrence but there
are some people who actually believed
that no this might actually have been
selected for in natural selection
because if there's a lot of oxygen
hanging around in the cell that oxygen
you know more than you need that oxygen
might actually react with your ATP and
and create other harmful compounds in
the cell and this might be a way of kind
of sopping up the harmful oxygen that's
actually hanging around the cell so who
knows but it's an interesting idea that
you have this one enzyme that can react
with ribulose biphosphate and carbon
dioxide and if that happens we just get
our regular calvin cycle or it can react
with ribulose biphosphate and oxygen and
actually fix oxygen into these two
molecules especially the phospho
glycolate which we think is a waste
compound and if you just went on and on
in the calvin cycle in this way you will
not produce any useful any useful sugars
so in the next video what I want to do
is study some plants that have been able
to get by this photorespiration problem
and you can imagine photorespiration
could be a really big big deal or it
could be very harmful in situations
where one it's very important for a
plant to be a very productive of sugars
and it can also we'll see it can be a
problem in well it's definitely a
problem if there's a huge amount of
oxygen content but we're in the next
video I'm going to show you plants that
have gotten around this problem by
instead of performing c3 photosynthesis
which is kind of a classic calvin cycle
that I just showed you they perform c4
photosynthesis and I'll show you what
that means in the next video